so hi everyone and be before I begin I
just want to do a little bit of a survey
uh can you raise your hand if you've
ever used a plug-in an add-on or
extension for any piece of software ever
yeah I expect a lot of hands up can you
raise your hand again if you've ever
written a plug-in add-on or extension
okay a couple more all right now here's
the really hard one have you ever
written a piece of software that
accommodates plugins add-ons or
extensions
okay okay and now here's the final level
of plug-in Mastery have you ever written
a library that can be used to define
plugins add-ons or extensions within a
host program
all right oh hey hey cool there we go
all right cool well that's cool thanks
for the participation
um so yeah my name is Travis and today
we're going to be talking about how to
write plug-in friendly applications in
Python let's go over today's agenda so
first we're going to Define what plugins
are so we have a clear kind of
theoretical concept of what it is
we'll also be talking about some
examples of plug-in systems in the wild
and then after that we're going to talk
about why or why not you should write a
plug-in friendly application
and then um once we have decided that
yes indeed we want to do that we're
going to talk about how it's done and
I'm going to walk you through the
creation of a project it's actually
going to be a creation of a image search
CLI application so
cool and then finally we are going to
talk about a real world example where I
um talk about something from my work and
how to retrofit a existing piece of code
to be plug-in friendly
cool so a little bit more about who I am
um so yeah first and foremost of a
python programmer I started writing
python back in version 2.6 so that was
about 2010 2011. so I'm definitely have
been around for the version two days
um this is actually my second time here
at python pycon de I gave a talk last
year on how to use osm data together
with python and postgres
and if you want to learn more about me
including my last year's talk you can go
to travisatherway.com lots of good stuff
there and then if you want to know more
about the code that I've written please
check me out on GitHub there's actually
quite a few things that I've done there
um yeah
all right and then uh where do I work uh
I work at a company called Anaconda I've
been working there for just over a year
now and um there I primarily work on the
open source package manager conda and so
conda is going to be the real world
example and so we have been working
quite busy in the last year to open this
application up make it more plug-in
friendly and conda is written in Python
cool and so finally who are you ideally
you're all python programmers uh because
I'm only going to be showing python code
um and then I also would be nice to have
a little bit of experience building your
own packages you never have to have
built a package but as long as uploading
something to Pi pis it doesn't sound
super scary then this is going to be
good because we're going to be using
python python packages as a way to
distribute plugins and then yeah most
importantly you want to learn more about
plug-in architectures in Python
all right so first question what is even
a plug-in Let's uh take a look at a
textbook definition so plugin also
called add-on or extension is computer
software that adds new functions to a
host program without altering the host
program itself
and let's look at some examples of this
in the wild so if anyone's ever used
Sphinx which is the really popular
python documentation generator if you've
ever used Sphinx for example to add
automatic documentation from Doc strings
or add a new theme that's an example of
a Plugin or extension if you've ever
done anything on your browser such as
installing add-ons for Firefox or
extensions for Chrome those are plugins
or extensions same thing with vs code
those also have a wide world of plugins
that make the software uh much like yeah
much better to use and then in the world
of web we have projects like Django
which has a ton of different extensions
that you can install install and
download for that and then finally we
have a web platform CMS platforms
WordPress and Drupal and those have a
very very big ecosystem of plugins and
and the thing to remember about these
projects is that I mean maybe for the
example of the Firefox right but a lot
of these projects would be not nearly as
good if they didn't have a entire
ecosystem of plugins to use for it
all right so how exactly do plugins work
um so I'm going to talk about the
quote-unquote plug-in mechanism as I'm
calling it and it relies on two
different things
um kind of two different abstract
Concepts we have the host program and
then we have the plug-in program
and so the host program has a couple
different responsibilities
um it's you can kind of think of it as
the development platform it's
responsible for choosing a language and
perhaps providing a default set of
libraries so if we go back to our
examples WordPress if you're writing a
plug-in for WordPress you're most likely
going to be using PHP if you're writing
an extension or a new plugin for Django
you're going to be using python
um yeah and then the pros the host
program also defines something that are
called Hooks and then the plug-in
program provides the implementation for
these hooks
so what exactly are plug-in hooks you
might ask yourself well they are defined
by the host program as I said and
provide an interface that plugins use
and the results and this results in an
implementation that the host program can
use to extend or modify its
functionality and so on the right hand
side we have a diagram that I've written
and it basically just shows the
relationships between the host program
creating a hook saying hey plugin this
is what you need to provide me and then
the plugin takes that hook and says
great I'm going to put my implementation
inside of it and then the host program
uses this implementation
and then other than having a system of
hooks and implementations plugins also
need a way to be distributed and so
right here I've listed three different
ways that you can distribute plugins and
the the top most is what I would say is
the most tightly integrated and then as
we go down it gets less so
and so on the very top we have the host
program provide providing an installer
for you so you don't even have to leave
the application you just basically go to
a particular plugin section or extension
section and then you can search and add
them from there so vs code and Google
Chrome are great examples of that
and then if we go down we now leave the
host program and we were relying instead
on a package manager to install the
plugin
and so this can be done via npm or pip
or conda and this is where basically you
have the host program is packaged as a
python package and then the plug-in
program is packaged as a another python
package and when you install the two
together the host program becomes
magically aware of the plugin program
and it can begin using it and then the
last thing I wanted to list is
um sometimes applications can specify a
folder where you simply drag and drop
the contents of the plugin code there
and then it's dynamically read and then
it's um made available to the host
program
and this is done in applications such as
Drupal
so now that we know a lot more about how
plugins function and how they're
distributed let's ask the question of
whether or not the application itself
should be plug-in friendly
and so here I have several pros and cons
and we're going to go through each of
them and so the first pro is that
plugins enable you to grow a community
of developers writing plugins like I
said before where would a lot of those
other applications be if it weren't for
the huge community of people writing and
extend and extending the functionality
of the host program but on the other
side of that you when you open up your
program to executing third-party code
you also do uh involve a security risk
so yeah and basically what you have to
have is a list of verified plugins
although I want to I want to briefly
mention that I saw a very interesting
talk on webassembly yesterday and I
really thought it was interesting how
webassembly could potentially help solve
this problem because webassembly would
allow you to essentially execute plug-in
code inside of a Sandbox so very
interesting okay so back over to the
pros um so you're when you write when
you choose a plug-in architecture it can
make your application very highly
adaptable and so not only can you
accommodate the use cases that you know
about today your application could
accommodate the use cases it doesn't
even know about that could appear in the
future and a really easy example of this
is to think about if you have an
application that supports Json and XML
file types now
but let's say in the future we have some
new file type that your application has
to support all you have to do is simply
write another plugin to accommodate that
I know it's not that easy but in theory
it could be that easy and so um yeah and
then moving from Back to the cons so
when you do have this plug-in
architecture you are increasing the
complexity of the code
um specifically the host program because
your host program not only has to worry
about what it does it now has to worry
about registering and using an entire
system of plugins and so for
applications like vs code or Firefox
this can be highly complex because we
have actually a built-in plug-in manager
in the application but even if you're
Distributing your plugins via python
packages you still have to have code in
there to register the plugin and then
use them and then make the plugins
configurable to use so that's all added
complexity for your program
and then back over to the pros not only
is it good for building a kind of large
open source community of of plug-in
contributors you can use this for
internal projects at any um yeah small
mid or large firms and yeah they're a
good way to help organize teams you can
have one team specifically working on
the host program where multiple other
teams take ownership of a single plug-in
that they write to help them in their
work
and then back over to the cons the very
last thing is that now that you have a
plug-in system you're forced to maintain
a distribution mechanism
and so this was kind of talked about in
The increased complexity but yeah um so
for example if you want to have a host
program but then you want to break out
some functionality into a plug-in well
now you have to worry about keeping
those two up to date those will then
have different versions those have to be
managed as different python packages and
yeah that's all just added
administrative overhead
but we're going to assume that everyone
has weighed the pros and cons and has
thought yeah I'm ready to write a
plug-in application this definitely fits
my need well good news I'm here to show
you how to do it in Python
um yeah and so what we're going to do is
we're going to be using a library called
pluggy
and so um yeah this is a very relatively
simple Library I would say and it
provides a framework for dividing Hooks
and implementing plug-in Hooks and
pluggy lies at the core of Pi test Pi
test plug-in system which is a very
popular
um yeah it's a very popular testing
framework and it is now
um reached I think as of a little bit
ago sir maybe actually I don't know how
long ago but it is now at version 1.0
and yeah it's a really really nice
library with a very narrow scope of what
it does so
and so
um in our example what we're going to
use plugy to do is we're going to be
able to define the hooks that our host
program
um within uh we're going to Define hooks
that our plugins are going to use to uh
as to implement
and then um using pluggy what we'll be
also be able to do is use Python
packages as a means of distribution so
we won't have to write our own internal
plug-in Mech registering and
installation mechanism in our
application we'll simply use Python
packaging as a way to install or
uninstall plugs
cool okay so now the example application
um I wanted to pick something really
kind of interesting to do so and I and
because I work on conda I work on CLI
applications so I said myself hmm
what kind of application do I want to
write well I really like pictures of
rabbits and cats and dogs and I thought
wow it'd be really cool to write a CLI
application that can get me as many
pictures of rabbits cats and dogs as
possible so what we'll do is we're going
to write a CLI application and the
plug-in Hook is going to allow us to
install different search backends so we
might initially write our application to
use Google image but then we can allow
plug-in authors to add other search
backends such as Imgur or even unsplash
cool and so right now what I'll do is
I'm going to do I'm walking I'm going to
walk you through defining the plug-in
hook and then I'm going to walk you
through
um creating the plugin implementation
so let's and and during this as I walk
through we're going to first look at the
host program side of things and then
afterwards we're going to look at the
plug-in program side effects
so first with the host program and when
you write an application in plugy you
start off by importing the plugin of the
plugin module
and then in pluggy applications there
are two very important objects that you
have to create basically as Singleton
objects and the first one is a hook
specification marker and then the second
one is a hook implementation marker and
so the hook specification marker is used
on the host program to specify which
plug-in hooks you want to make available
and then the hook implementation marker
is going to be used on the plug-in side
to say hey look this is my
implementation for this specific plugin
hook
and how do we do and so let's look at
how to use the hook specification marker
so the first thing that I do is I create
a class and this class is called app
hook specs and it functions purely here
as a namespace I'm going to as I when I
register my hook specifications I'll use
this class later but just know this
class isn't doing anything special it's
purely serving as a namespace
and then if we look below we can see
that we're now using our hook spec
object as a decorator to Mark the first
plug and hook that we have and this
plug-in Hook is a um basically you can
think of it as just the callable in this
case it's a class method and it has the
name search backend and then we're using
a type pin to say hey this is going to
return a search back and hook objects
and now this search back and hook object
is a custom data type that I'm going to
talk about next
and so I um what we what we do here is
we've we Define a search back and hook
object and we do this because what we
want to do is we want to hold more than
just the
the search function right the the
function the the piece of implementation
logic that goes and grabs our search
results we want to be able to store
other pieces of data on top of it such
as the name
and so this class is a very simple class
that inherits from name Tuple and this
basically means that it has a small
memory footprint it's immutable so we
don't change it and we don't usually
want to change this and then below what
we do is we define the properties on the
object the first one is going to be the
name and this is the unique identifier
for the search back-end plugin and so in
our search
um in our search CLI application if we
wanted to then say hey I'm going to do
an image search and then I want to use
Google and then emker we would basically
identify it by the name that we defined
here and then below that we have a uh
this search property and then that's
going to be a callable and so you can
think of this as the function that goes
out and grabs the search results from
whatever search backend we want to use
okay so now that we've talked about how
to define the hook specifications on the
host program let's move over to the
plugin program and what you're looking
at here is more or less the entire
implementation of this so let's walk
through this line by line and so what we
first do is from our host program we are
going to import that hook implementation
marker object and then the search
backend hook object and So Below what we
do is we use the hook implementation
marker as a decorator on a on this
search back-end function and one thing
to remember is that in when we Define
the hook specification we we basically
made it we put it as a decorator over a
method that was called search backend
now we're putting this hook
implementation over a function called
search backend and so the important
thing is that these two names need to
match up so this is how pluggy
internally says oh great hey this is the
hook specification here's the hook
implementation boom now we have a pair
and so um in our hook implementation
what we do is we are returning the
search backend hook object that we just
talked about earlier it's going to
define a name which would just be the
plugin name for this and then it's going
to also Define a search function
and so the search function here would
accept a search query and then it would
do yeah whatever a search function does
you can imagine it would make an HTTP
request or do any sort of yeah adding
any sort of access tokens or anything
like that
um but yeah I left the implementation
out for brevity so yeah
and then just to really
um drill in this whole procedure I just
went through I wanted to show kind of a
visual summary because I know some
people here might
um yeah be visual of Learners and this
might kind of sink in a little bit
better but yeah um so from light so from
left to right what it does is that we we
basically we have a plug-in that
implements this search back-end hook and
that hook returns this what I'm calling
a plug-in configuration object the
search back-end hook object that then
has two properties it has a search
function that we can use to retrieve
results and then it also has a um it has
the name of the plugin and then this is
in turn used by the host program so this
is how we get from left going from the
plug-in all the way to the right to the
host program
cool
all right
and so I now that we have the hook
specifications defined we have the
plug-in implementation implementation
there we need to make our host program
aware of the plugin and I said earlier
that yeah you know you use Python
packaging you pip install this stuff you
have these two packages and they kind of
just know that they're there but let's
figure out exactly how this works
because it's not quite Magic
so um and so this is the final step in
the mostly in the plugin and pluggy
applications is that we want to tie
everything together and so let's walk
through this code line by line so first
we do this by implementing a plug-in
manager object and it just takes the
project name
as a as an argument
and then
um we what we do now is we use the
plugin manager object to add the hook
specs and remember before when I talked
about this app hook specs class as
basically being a um a namespace
um yeah so that's going to
take all the methods on that class and
then register them as plug-in hooks
and then finally what we have is uh
we're going to call this load setup
tools entry points method on the plugin
manager object and it takes the project
name which is important because that
needs to be referenced later in
something called a setup tools entry
point
ah but what is this entry point stuff
you're talking about I've never heard of
that and I don't blame you because
before I use pluggy I hadn't quite heard
of this before either but from packaging
from the
packaging.python.org website they
provide this lovely explanation so entry
points or mechanisms for an install
distribution to advertise components it
provides to be discovered and used by
their code and so in our case the um the
plug-in system is going to be that
installed distribution and it's
advertising its code to our host program
it's saying hey host program I got some
code over here that might interest you
if you want to come check it out so
that's how that works
and what does this actually look like in
the code well if you're I showed two
different examples here we have a pi
project.tomo file and we also have a
setup.pi file and really it's just um as
simple as having
um two nice little entries
um this is the more modern way of doing
it but what we do is we have
project.entrypoint.app that's that
project name that from earlier and so
then we are basically assigning Google
image search and then with this what we
do is we're essentially just um it's
this is like the module path to where
the code lives so our our search our so
the plug-in module name is called app
Google image search and then where the
code lives is a module called main so
dot Main and then we can see the exact
same thing in the setup.python
cool and so now um finally we can tie
everything together and actually call
this plug-in hook and this is an example
main function of how that might look
um and so first we have the main
function accepting a search query and
then the search back ends it might use
and then below we have a um we're
creating a list called called search
functions where we will collect all of
the different search functions that we
want to run and so for in this for Loop
what we do is we use the plugin manager
that we invoked earlier and the plugin
manager has a hook property
and then the hook property is aware of
all the different plug-in Hooks and so
when you call search backend it's going
to return an interval of all the
different results of all the different
Hooks and so for our case right it's
going to be that search backend hook
object that has those nice properties
like name and search for the search
function and so when we Loop through
this we basically are saying hey
hey search plugin are you currently
configured are you in this back ends set
thing and then if it is then we just add
that function there and then later on
we're going to call it so that's a
really simple example of how to how to
use that um in action so cool
and I'm going to skip the Recaps just so
we I think we're getting a little bit
low on time
but what I want to talk to you about is
um
this was just a toy example right and
um not very useful but as I was writing
this talk I wanted to make an actually
useful prod project that could be used
in real life this is exactly what this
project is it's called lats and you can
find it on my GitHub account it has lots
of documentation it's also got I even
wrote a Imgur plug-in it's got a couple
built-in plugins it's a real deal thing
and actually I just wanted to show it to
you real quick so this is the command
line application you run it you get some
help messages there and when you do
Flats search husky hopefully we're going
to find some dogs it will print out this
lovely table
thank you demo gods and when you click
that we get a nice little dog from him
girl that's pretty awesome yeah so
good deal go check that code out it's um
yeah it's definitely it's it was a labor
of love that's for sure
I just gotta get back to my applications
all right
so getting to the end of the talk I said
something about a real world real world
application okay what is all this conda
stuff oh yeah that's right I've worked
for a company called Anaconda where we
write tools for data scientists and one
of those tools is the conda package
manager and so the really cool thing
about everything I just showed you and
also about the way that things are set
up in lats is that it is almost exactly
the same setup it's it's the setup that
almost exactly the same in condom so
that's awesome
um and if you want to talk about how it
works in condo later come find me after
the talk or you can also post on the
Discord Channel I'd be more than happy
to answer questions there
and if you didn't know conda is a
package manager we have over 30 million
active users by some counts the project
is now over 10 years old and because the
project is getting older
it's basically
[Music]
um
it's yeah it's starting to show its age
and in order to help Breathe new life
into it excuse me
um we wanted to start developing plug-in
hooks that would allow people to extend
the functionality and we also want to do
this in order to help people get more
involved in its development and so for
that reason we have
created
currently three new plug-in hooks for it
and I believe the most successful now is
the is the solver and for those that
don't know what solvers are basically
the solver is when you run conda install
um it it's in charge of figuring out how
to find all the different packages for
that particular command
um so yeah this gets more complicated
the more packages you have
um but one success that we've seen is
we've been able to incorporate the work
that have been done in the Mamba project
and now the um that word can be accessed
and conda directly and then we are
really happy because now that we have a
solver plug-in hook this means that as
developments continue in the world of
solvers our project can now adapt and be
more
um yeah more responsive and be able to
incorporate this new technology easier
then we also have other ones for writing
sub commands and creating virtual
packages
um and so the future of this I've been
working on a couple proposals for adding
a plug-in hook that would allow people
to further customize networking and so
this would allow you to for example
if you wanted to grab a package from SSH
or use different network transport
protocols you could be able to do that
with the networking plugin and the other
one is that we're we're currently
talking about adding a pre and post
command execution there's a lot of
different functionality that you can add
if you can interrupt the various Honda
commands before and after they're run so
that's really exciting
and so yeah and I I think I'm getting uh
to the end my concluding thoughts so
yeah I just want to let you know that uh
plugins they can be a really great way
to organize your application especially
if you want to collaborate and work
together with different people to build
a really cool application like I said it
could be used for open source projects
but it can also be used internally as
well
um but as you do this uh carefully plan
the parts that you want to expose as
plug-in hooks because remember as you
write these and as people actually write
plugins which is awesome right you're
then you're going to have to support
these Hooks and you're going to have to
be very mindful of how
changes could potentially break those
applications so this is not something to
be done lightly but it can be a fun kind
of thought experiment if you just want
to go goof around and create your own
python project and add new plug-in hooks
like I did this year so I had a lot of
fun doing that and then if you have an
existing code one thing I want to make
sure that you do is to always document
the internals because as you open up
your application with various plug-in
Hooks and especially with a language
like python especially if it's open
source people are going to go digging
around and they're going to run into
errors that they might not be able to
yeah easily solve by themselves and so
when they can go through and read your
code and actually make sense of it it's
going to help them and it's going to
reduce the amount of issues that you get
on your issue tracker so
all right so thank you everyone I really
appreciate the time that everyone took
today to sit down and yeah I welcome
questions if it's time for it
thank you Travis we have time for a few
questions
um so most voted on the slido is would
you implement a default back-end art
coded or already as a plugin which is
burned out together with the main
program
yeah um so I would always Implement a
default and I can actually show you uh
what this looks like in uh plugy itself
and so basically
let's take a look
so if we look at this code down here the
one thing I didn't cover uh about pluggy
is that it can load stuff from entry
points but then it also has this
register method that you can register
your own kind of internal Hooks and so
for the the example program I wrote I
have two different built-in things for
one was for unsplash and the other one's
a placeholder it's just really simple
kind of more for testing so yeah I would
always recommend doing um default
implementations and when you do the
default implementation then you also
give plug-in authors a great kind of
starting point for learning how to
actually write plugins for your
application so
cool
um okay I think we are just time for one
uh can we Define the data type structure
of the result developed by the plugin
via plugin
okay so the the three are you mean like
kind of like the type hints I think so
like what will be returned by the Yeah
Yeah Yeah so that's so the the really
interesting thing about
um what I talked about here let me see
if I can find it um
right so this this whole step where you
register a hook and you say yeah return
that that doesn't actually do any
validation and um what I would like to
do would basically be to make to make it
more user friendly for the plug-in
developer is to actually write some sort
of validation to say Hey you gave me a
plug-in hook implementation but you
didn't return this object can you please
go back and try to return the object
currently unplugging pluggy doesn't
actually um enforce that but um yeah
maybe that would be a thing that we can
that could be added to the project so
this could be a contribution yeah
perhaps perhaps that'd be really cool so
it's a great project I really I like
using it so thank you again for your
presentation
and yes
thank you